[Música]
en 1993 por primera vez en la historia
bolivia lograba la clasificación al
mundial de fútbol esta vez por sus
propios méritos porque ya había
clasificado en otras ocasiones
anteriores pero a partir de invitación
esta vez será a partir de nuestro propio
juego nuestro propio merecimiento y no
ha sido una historia sencilla lo que ha
ocurrido es que hemos debido enfrentar a
rivales muy poderosos en el transcurso
de esa eliminatoria de hecho nos hemos
enfrentado al brasil que eventualmente
en el 94 iba a ser el campeón del mundo
y también nos hemos enfrentado a un gran
rival como puede ser uruguay cinco
equipos componían el grupo de bolivia
para clasificar al mundial de los cuales
solamente dos podían clasificar por lo
tanto los partidos contra uruguay han
sido muy difíciles hemos ganado tres a
uno en la paz pero hemos perdido 2 a 1
en montevideo uno puede decir que hemos
perdido ese partido a partir de un
arbitraje bastante polémico y un tiempo
de adicción
uno podría decir de que la derrota de
bolivia en ese partido de montevideo ha
sido relativamente injusta y la victoria
de uruguay lo acercaba peligrosamente a
la segunda posición que te daba el
derecho de jugar el mundial directamente
bolivia en ese partido pudo haber
perdido no solamente el encuentro sino
también la clasificación al mundial
de todas maneras al finalizar el partido
el entrenador de bolivia javier
azkargorta no ha hecho énfasis ni en el
resultado ni en el rival él ha hecho
énfasis en las propias posibilidades de
nuestro equipo en nuestros propios
recursos y él emite una frase muy
interesante él dice a pesar de este
resultado los bolivianos tenemos que
saber que tenemos derecho a soñar y a
ganar
un año después en eeuu-1994 bolivia
juega el primer mundial de fútbol por su
propio mérito y ahora un niño en ese
momento he pensado de que quizás no es
necesario ser resentido con el pasado
para poder progresar
que quizás el hecho de que hayamos
perdido la guerra del pacifico no
necesariamente significa que todo lo que
los bolivianos hagamos sea en función
del fracaso que tal vez el hecho de que
hemos tenido una mala campaña en la
guerra del chaco no significa que lo que
nosotros hagamos esté diseñado hacia la
falla
eran ideas que con mis amigos de colegio
las comentábamos pero no sabíamos
sustentar las de manera adecuada pero si
nos inspiraban pero no sabíamos cómo
transmitir las y tampoco sabíamos el
valor de esas ideas tienes el derecho a
soñar y el derecho a ganar
el tiempo ha ido pasando me he
convertido en psicólogo y he obtenido
una beca para estudiar en inglaterra y
he ingresado al maravilloso mundo de la
construcción de paz y de las
neurociencias cognitivas
he conocido el trabajo de excelentes
psicólogos a nivel mundial que durante
décadas de esfuerzo tesonero nos han
dado excelentes conclusiones con
respecto a cómo la humanidad va
avanzando y con respecto a cuál es la
base de ese progreso
lo que voy a plantear ahora es que la
salud mental es la base de la
civilización humana de que no se puede
hablar de progreso ni de civilización
sin salud mental
y que los gobiernos que invierten en
salud mental hacen que la población
tenga más oportunidades de poder vivir
en paz positiva y sobre todo al invertir
en salud mental la eficacia y eficiencia
de las organizaciones y de las
instituciones tiende a ser bastante alta
pero también lo que quiero decir ahora
es que la inversión en salud mental y en
la gente hace que el mundo de hecho esté
mejorando
por ejemplo hace 200 años atrás la
cantidad de personas que no sabían leer
y escribir en alrededor de 8 sobre 10
hoy menos de 2 personas sobre 10 no
saben leer y escribir las restantes 8 si
podemos y eso qué significa significa
mejores oportunidades educativas para
todos en este momento preciso de nuestra
vida
lo que también parece que está mejorando
en el mundo es la percepción sobre la
propia realidad afectiva así es son cada
vez más las personas de manera paulatina
que generan con base en sus propios
recursos nuevos mecanismos para salir
adelante por ellos mismos
de todas maneras pues está claro que
los ciudadanos tenemos preocupaciones
legítimas
nos preocupa seguramente la violencia
nos preocupa seguramente las migraciones
masivas el cambio climático la
corrupción y tal vez deberíamos pedir a
los gobiernos que nos ayuden a erradicar
de una vez este tipo de preocupaciones
pero aunque tengamos preocupaciones
legítimas
también es bueno saber de que el mundo
está mejorando en varias otras áreas
por ejemplo la cantidad de personas que
vivían en extrema pobreza hace 200 años
atrás era alrededor de 9 sobre 10 hoy
menos de 2 personas en el mundo viven en
extrema pobreza y eso qué significa para
nosotros significa que los seres humanos
podemos vivir vidas saludables y vidas
largas y vidas resilientes
hace 200 años atrás el acceso a las
vacunas era casi nulo casi ninguna
persona estaba vacunada hoy más del 80%
de las personas en el mundo si lo
estamos y nosotros somos la evidencia de
aquello por lo tanto es muy probable que
tú vivas en términos cronológicos una
vida más larga en comparación a tus
papás
y lo que también está mejorando en el
mundo disminuyendo en este caso es la
mortalidad infantil hace 200 años atrás
4 de cada 10 niños morían en los
primeros cinco años de vida hoy menos de
dos de cada diez niños van a morir en el
mundo en el mismo lapso de tiempo
y eso qué significa significa que por
primera vez en la historia la humanidad
ha creado tecnología y mecanismos entre
los cuales está la psicología para
cuidar de aquel que no puede cuidarse a
sí mismo
no estoy planteando de qué se vive en un
mundo ideal estoy planteando de que el
mundo está mejorando y buena parte del
progreso se debe a la ciencia y parece
que el progreso es algo imparable una
ciencia de más vista desde la filosofía
de la ilustración es decir el
conocimiento es infinito y tiene que
estar al servicio de la gente
ahora
como investigador universitario yo me
pregunto cuál puede ser nuestra postura
con respecto a un mundo que está
mejorando como bolivianos los que
estamos acá cómo podemos conectarnos con
algún tipo de evidencia que dice que el
mundo está progresando por lo menos en
algunas áreas sobre todo cómo podemos
relacionar un mundo que mejora con la
premisa que he dado al inicio de la
charla de que como bolivianos tenemos
derecho a soñar y tenemos derecho a
ganar
lo que he intentado hacer en mis clases
de pregrado y de posgrado en especial en
la universidad mayor de san andrés es
intentar comunicar y transmitir
conocimiento pero con un lenguaje basado
en la esperanza la esperanza es un
producto del cerebro y además viene
sustentada con cierto tipo de evidencia
empírica y el mensaje que quiero mandar
a los estudiantes de psicología en
especial del pregrado es que si la salud
mental es la base de la civilización y
del progreso de la humanidad y la
psicología como ciencia realmente
estudia la salud mental puede que ellos
hayan escogido una de las profesiones
más importantes en la edad contemporánea
ahora mismo
pero alguien puede preguntar tenemos
esperanza muy bien esperanza para que
entonces ese para que de la esperanza lo
podemos responder desde la filosofía lo
podemos hacer a partir de las
reflexiones de una mujer maravillosa
valiente que se llamaba en rne que ha
luchado contra las ideologías de odio en
su país de origen y también lo podemos
hacer incorporando los razonamientos de
un excelente filósofo ahora mismo que se
llama estefan moliné o que se ha criado
en el reino unido y ahora vive en canadá
es posible que ambos eslálon afirmar que
una propiedad de todo ser racional es
intentar vivir vidas largas y prósperas
por lo tanto yo creo que es posible en
nuestro país a partir de la ciencia de
la esperanza vivir vidas largas y
prósperas
pero alguien también puede preguntar
vidas largas y prósperas pero para qué y
con base en el sacrificio y el tesón de
los más grandes psicólogos de bolivia
que han formado profesionales durante
años de años y quiero proponer que lo
que debemos hacer es llevar la
psicología a la gente dejar de esperar
que la gente venga a la psicología y
para eso me he preguntado qué tipo de
aporte yo puedo dar para llevar la
psicología a la gente he pensado en un
aporte simple pero de alto impacto he
pensado en un aporte sencillo pero
aplicable a la vida diaria creo que ya
es tiempo de que los bolivianos hablemos
seriamente sobre cómo construir nuestra
mentalidad ganadora
una mentalidad ganadora no solamente
consiste en la capacidad de resistir
aquello que te está ocurriendo
sino también consiste en que bajo tus
propios recursos en aquello que te
interesa triunfes
entonces resulta que como la psicología
es una ciencia bastante amplia los
psicólogos si hemos estudiado este
término que se llama mentalidad ganadora
un excelente psicólogo que se llamaba
bandura le puso de nombre autoeficacia y
otros psicólogos que se llamaba
mcclelland le puso de nombre motivación
de logro porque surgió una pregunta muy
importante para todos nosotros cómo está
estructurada la mentalidad del boliviano
que triunfa
y parece que existen cinco factores que
constituyen ese tipo de mentalidad
ganadora el primer factor se llama
logros de ejecución
eso quiere decir que en el lugar donde
estés intentar rendir al máximo de tus
posibilidades o por lo menos rendir un
poco más de lo que normalmente se espera
logros de ejecución
el segundo factor se llama sensación de
orgullo está bien que te sientas
orgulloso y orgullosa del esfuerzo que
has realizado está bien que te sientas
orgullosa y orgullosa de los resultados
que estás llevando a tu oficina a tu
familia oa tu trabajo una sensación de
orgullo que nadie va a poder borrar el
resto de tu vida
otra fuente de la mentalidad ganadora
se llama aprendizaje vicario que
básicamente quiere decir que te juntes
con personas más inteligentes que vos
que sean más capaces que tú en algún
área de la vida y que aprendas esas
personas y que sobre todo transfiera el
conocimiento obtenido a personas que
realmente lo necesitan
otra fuente se llama persuasión verbal
que en términos sencillos quiere decir
que en términos verbales por supuesto
tienes que tener una relación más o
menos saludable contigo mismo tu cerebro
escucha lo que vos opinas de él
y básicamente no eres lo que haces ni lo
que comes eres lo que piensas
y el último factor que podría constituir
la mentalidad del boliviano que triunfa
se llama persistencia es decir insistir
a pesar de los errores incorporar el
error como parte del aprendizaje
ahora esto en términos teóricos
obviamente suena bastante sencillo
en términos prácticos es mucho más
difícil
cuando terminado mis estudios
especialización en inglaterra lo que he
querido hacer era volver a trabajar a
una organización educativa que me había
cobijado por alrededor de nueve años
donde he conocido a personas
maravillosas personas que me han
orientado me han cuidado y me han
protegido
he intentado rendir en esa organización
educativa al tope de mis posibilidades y
debo reconocer que en muchos días he
sido realmente feliz me he sentido
realizado pero cuando intentado
reincorporarme a su organización el
mensaje era directo
marcelo no queremos contar contigo
no han querido recontratar me
y ha sido un periodo bastante frustrante
en mi vida un periodo también un poco
oscuro dentro del ámbito profesional
pero después he pensado que yo también
ha nacido con el derecho a ganar y a
soñar y de que se intentó realizar
algunos de mis sueños puedo inspirar a
otras personas a que se animen a hacer
lo mismo he pensado que en ese momento
lo que yo debería haber hecho y en
realidad sí lo hice es generar mi propia
mentalidad ganadora
y lo que básicamente he hecho es
resistir y persistir
persistir y resistir y tal vez gracias a
esos dos elementos es que ahora puedo
contribuir a dos de las universidades
más poderosas de bolivia
este entrenador tenía que preparar un
partido mano a mano de ida y vuelta
contra uno de los mejores equipos de su
tiempo un equipo muy poderoso a nivel
mundial seguramente con jugadores de una
técnica superior a la que él tenía en
sus suyos propios este entrenador
seguramente también ha pensado que su
equipo aunque estaba en desventaja tenía
derecho a ganar
y lo que ha hecho en el partido
definitivo
lo que ha hecho antes de jugar la
eliminatoria real ha sido reunir a sus
jugadores y no hablarles de casi nada
simplemente hacerles una pregunta
una pregunta que seguramente todos los
bolivianos que estamos acá nos podríamos
hacer una pregunta muy importante que
puede definir tu vida laboral por lo
menos la pregunta es cómo quieres ser
recordado
seguramente no podemos obligar a las
personas a que se destaquen siempre y
seguramente tal vez están de acuerdo
conmigo en que no puede ser exitoso el
100 por ciento de las veces que intentas
hacer algo en tu vida en todos los
aspectos de tu vida no se puede pero
aunque esa sea la realidad podemos
mandar un mensaje poderoso a los jóvenes
de bolivia podemos decirles donde estés
destaca t
no pidas que la parada dificultad
disminuya simplemente porque todo estás
ahí
cuando quería hacer mi tesis de maestría
ninguno de mis profesores en inglaterra
se ha acercado y me ha dicho mira a
marcelo porque vos proviene de un país
cuyos indicadores de desarrollo humano
son muy bajos lo que vamos a hacer es
disminuir la nota mínima de aprobación a
ver si tú alcanzas
lo que en realidad han hecho conmigo es
motivarme inspirarme para que yo pueda
proyectar la imagen de un boliviano que
triunfa a partir de su propio esfuerzo
y si tú me preguntas en este momento
como quiero ser recordado
yo quiero ser recordado como un
psicólogo que ama a bolivia como un
psicólogo con un profundo apego al
método científico porque sabemos que
nuestra ciencia mientras más apego
tengamos al método científico mejor
servicio vamos a poder brindar a nuestro
prójimo pero también como un psicólogo
profundamente admirador del gran
espíritu de superación humana
una de las mejores noticias que vas a
recibir hoy es que bolivia te necesita
tu país te necesita pero bolivia no
necesita buenos profesionales
bolivia necesita grandísimos expertos
con una amplia formación técnica pero
también humana
y quizás tal vez estés de acuerdo
conmigo en que no solamente bolivia te
necesita sino también el mundo te puede
necesitar pero el mundo no te debe nada
el mundo va a respetar la contribución
que hagas a él como en cuanto y en tanto
tú a partir de tu trabajo y la
constancia puedas elevar la calidad de
vida de las personas en cuanto y en
tanto a partir de tu sacrificio puedas
impactar positivamente la vida de las
personas que te rodean
contribuye al mundo generando una visión
individual de tu propia mentalidad
ganadora
gracias
[Aplausos]